[Applause]
on saturday morning
it came a cocktail of black mud water
and debris
consuming dozens of homes
there was a huge noise as though an
airplane had crashed
houses on both sides collapsed into the
river
neighbours watched in horror as litres
of mud continued to pour into the town
of atomy
west of tokyo this bridge
also unable to withstand its power
the number of missing people is growing
as almost a hundred are evacuated
rescue teams tasked with finding
survivors weighed through filthy water
and past submerged cars as the military
also
joined the search japan's prime minister
is lending further resources to limit
the loss of life
we're doing everything we can to put
people's lives first
but due to the weather we're unable to
use helicopters and drones
we're preparing for further disasters
and we'll continue with our rescue
operation
it's thought record rainfall had
loosened dirt over the past
week in some parts 12 inches fell in
just
two days increasing the risk for the
communities
built on these steep mountainsides
with more heavy rain forecast in the
coming days for a country
known for its valleys and mountains
there is inevitable nervousness
and of fear at the thought of more loss
ashna harinag
sky news